ça c'est le club de débats du lycée
privé d'un bloc combien de membres
avez-vous des mois elle et moi et moi
mais lui et moi oh moi même on s'en
fiche sur internet j'ai déjà oublié pour
quel club loue déjà c'est une véritable
aide si vous voulez faire bouger les
choses cette année vous allez devoir
vous entendre sur quelque chose je
réfute le fait que les études
supérieures ou trop chères études
supérieures effet la meilleure n'oublie
cette fille concentre toi plutôt sur ce
garçon qu'est valley high et il sera
qualifié pour le tournoi national et
harvard te donnera une bourse complète
c'était deux meilleurs orateurs du comté
ensemble vous participerez au tournoi
national
[Musique]
tout le monde est prêt
nous nous met des mois ne veulent pas
d'accord on peut dire que les coudes
pourquoi parler si vite pendant le débat
donc tout le monde s'est mis à parler
plus vite pour avoir plus de poids
mais on peut pas comprendre ce qu'a dit
je peux pas tu peux toi personne ne peut
y on a aucun atome crochu on n'est pas
d'accord c'est votre santé gymnase et
vie complètement opposées alors je vois
pas comment ça pourrait marseille
sculpture contre qui il s'agit de trois
ans à venir
tu va le gagner on sait tous les deux
pieds le meilleur de cette équipe on a
mérité d'être président on devrait tous
vanter les mérites de nos enfants est
agréable de voir aussi apprêtée bonne
chance à ta fille
ce n'est pas une question de chance
je fais les choses par moi-même de fait
qu'on se retrouve à étudier ensemble je
suis pas sûr d'être doué pour ça il faut
dire qu'ils n'étaient pas d'accord tu
adores est dans l'opposition
[Musique]
pendant toute ma vie je te déteste pas
pour ce que tu étais mais parce que je
croyais tu me détestaient aussi
je suis pas sûr qu'on soit vraiment doué
pour les grandes études j'avais l'esprit
est tellement occupée par les devoirs
les sortiront des personnes qui brille
par leur succès pour intégrer
l'établissement pour voter où ils ont
échoué mais tout le monde a fini par
faire quelque chose de sa vie
peut-être que ça m'aidera d'intégrer une
école ou peut-être que non j'ai juste
envie de gagner
alors c'est parti
[Musique]